you know I think for the first time in
recorded history Liz truss has got
something right the the windfall tax is
a labor idea standing up to the big
vested interest so we can help the
people of Britain in their moment of
need an energy policy for the people and
the planet labor ideas labor values
labor principles
now you know you know the crises we face
that I talked about might seem different
but they all come from One Source the
climate and nature crisis is caused by
the burning of fossil fuels the energy
bills crisis is caused by the fact that
we're exposed to the roller coaster of
fossil fuel prices
and the crisis of energy security comes
from the global Scramble for gas
these crises have the same ultimate
cause our dependence on fossil fuels
and all of them and all of them have the
same solution low-cost homegrown zero
carbon power for our country
you know you know today the cost of
solar and wind energy is nine times less
than that of gas this is the defining
truth of our age this is the undeniable
truth of our age it is cheaper to save
the planet than it is to destroy it
that that's why I am I'm so proud to say
a labor government will make Britain the
first country in the world to set and
achieve the target of zero carbon power
by 2030.
it'll save 93 billion pounds of energy
bills it will make Britain a clean
energy superpower and friends we will do
it by sweeping away that Tory Dogma that
is holding our country back it is within
our grasp let's hear it for doubling
onshore wind trebling solar power
quadrupling offshore wind tidal Power
Nuclear hydrogen power and all
underpinned by the best investment we
can make 60 billion pounds over a decade
to insulate 19 million cold drafty homes
saving a thousand pounds of bills
cutting carbon emissions mobilizing
thousands of businesses and yes friends
led by our brilliant labor local
authorities up and down Britain that's
what I mean by an energy policy for the
people and the planets
foreign
thank you
now you know what are the Tories offer
instead they tell us after 12 years in
power
after after four Tory Prime Ministers
after all their promises they say and
I'm not making this up the energy system
is broken
that's what they say friends who broke
the Energy System they did who banned
onshore wind they did who said cut the
green crap and drove our bills they did
who slashed home insulation
very good who deregulated the energy
Market who directed yeah yeah I've got
more I've even got more who deregulated
the energy market and let 32 companies
go bust
friends I've got an idea if we want to
mend the broken Energy System let's
start by getting rid of the Tories who
broke it
foreign
and guess what and guess what with these
Tories fracking is back the Tories
banned fracking in 2019 because they
said it was dangerous now they've moved
the goal posts under the Tories and I'm
not making this up either moderate
earthquakes are just fine
that's their position
so I say to you let every Tory MP and
candidate be asked where do you stand on
dangerous expensive fracking where do
you stand on breaking your Manifesto
promises friends let them try and sell
let them try and sell their Charter for
earthquakes to the people of Lancashire
Yorkshire the Midlands and communities
across the country we will hold them to
account on behalf of the British people
who do they say who do they choose who
do they choose to be solemnly entrusted
to look after the future of our planet
Jacob Reese MOG
19th century MOG a a man who says a man
who says we should extract every last
drop he says of oil and gas even though
it would mean three degrees of global
warming a man who says and I'm quoting
him trying to forecast the climate is
unrealistic the cost is probably
unaffordable
friends let's call it what it is this is
dangerous climate denial
thank you
if you want an energy policy for the
1820s Jacob Reese MOG is your man if you
want one for the 2020s we need a labor
government friend
and let me let me tell you this because
I listened carefully to the debate our
plans are not just about Transforming
Our Energy System they're about
Transforming Our economy too you know
there's a global race on for the jobs of
the future and Britain under the Tories
is losing it
uh let me tell you about itm power in
Sheffield they're one of the world
leaders in the hydrogen industry they
were looking at the UK for a new Factory
but seeing the lack of support on offer
from the British government they now
plan to go overseas I say it must and it
will be different under a labor
government it's time to invest in
Britain again friends
that's that's why Rachel Reeves and I
are today announcing a new institution
that will take back control of Britain's
economic Destiny government as partner
investor and yes shareholder working
with business a new National wealth fund
for Britain
and let me tell you what that's going to
do it's going to lead the world in
hydrogen lead the world in the Eevee
Revolution from the Northeast to the
West Midlands lead the world in green
steel from Port Talbert to scunthorpe
leave the world in decarbonizing
Industry from here on merseyside to
grangemouth leave the world in jobs from
the southwest to Scotland in offshore
wind good jobs at good wages with strong
trade Unions that's what I mean by a
green new deal that's what I mean by an
energy policy for the people and the
planet
and Friends it cuts to a deeper truth
and I heard this so clearly in the
debate the goal of the next Labor
government can't just be to Tinker round
the edges the hour is too late the
moment is too serious the next Labor
government will deliver fundamental
reform to the institutions of our
economy so we have an economy built by
working people for all working people
friends as it says on the party card
power wealth and opportunity in the
hands of the many not the few
so let me tell you here is the election
Choice lower energy bills with labor
higher bills under the Tories energy
security with labor energy insecurity
under the Tories millions of green jobs
with labor opportunities squandered
under the Tories leading the world again
in tackling the climate crisis with
labor climate delay and denial under the
Tories friends these are the stakes
don't let anyone tell you all parties
are the same don't let anyone tell you
politics doesn't matter don't let anyone
tell you nothing will change whoever you
vote for this is our mission this is our
chance let's protect the people and the
planet let's rise to this moment let's
lead and together let's transform our
country thank you very much